I am Bob hillerich I'm fifth-generation
bat manufacturer for health and Bradsby
Louisville Slugger baseball bats we used
to have 20 to 22 different steps in
making a baseball bat in the 60s and 70s
you had a guy sitting there with tools
hand turning and with pair of calipers
when we used to hand turn we would come
in here and we would get the particular
model that was calling for like this
model here is the actual Babe Ruth's bat
that we turned his bats off of you know
if you were good at you could turn one
in 10 to 15 minutes but today with the
treasures we have it's just a matter of
pressing a few buttons and changing from
one model to the next and the bats
running about right at 45 seconds bats
are coming off the CNC lathe plus or
minus three thousandths of an inch the
only thing is really left up to us is to
choose the right model in the correct
weight for the built for the bat being
selected when a player wants a new model
made I'm the guy who makes them they'll
send in the model I will take it
digitize it then use it in AutoCAD to
shape it and then you put it in our go
Ilan's program and install it into the
CNC lathe it's handed over to Danny
Bucket at our CNC machine and where he
makes the final determination of which
billet goes for which players bats then
it goes over for combination sanding and
once it's sanded the nubs are finally
cut off and we mark the bat either
through a burn branding process or
labouring process then it's finished the
weights are checked in three different
areas now to where we make sure that
every player gets the correct weight
then it's final checked and packed and
ready to ship out
why first started our finish and our
overall bat wasn't exactly what we
needed to be we looked at our product we
looked at the competition's product and
we said hey there's some neat
innovations out there how can we match
their innovations and make them better
we made the finishes our batch harder we
are making overall grains on the bat we
found out ways to tighten them up make
them stronger
keep the flaking down just basically
from step one do the very last step
we've been able to increase our
production and make them back to look
better and perform better there's only
one place to go when you're number one
and that's down there's not an employee
downstairs right now that doesn't
understand that we're making a better
bat now than we were five years ago
Oh